[Musique]
voilure tout vous êtes vous un accord de
coordonner un très bon s'appelle ouais
alors que là c'est très moche la faut
dire ce qui est c'est son nom change and
bonjour le magnifique ce bureau
présidentiel
magnifique va me permettre de déclarer
ma candidature je prends mes
responsabilités je suis prêt je pense je
pense je suis intimement convaincu je
propose je suis très clair j'ai bien
l'intention et je proposerai est ce que
je veux proposer une idée la suivante je
suis aussi est ce que je voudrais
également je veux je propose ce projet
je serai intraitable je suis seul à
porter ce message
les hôpitaux sont saturés et dans une
tribune du journal du dimanche 41
directeur médicaux de crise de l'ap-hp
assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
alerte il évoque une situation de
médecine de catastrophe et dit se
préparer à devoir je les cite faire un
tri des patients afin de sauver le plus
de vies possibles propose de commettre
un délit
sous les yeux des forces de l'ordre qui
ne diront rien je vous je vous propose
de vous embrasser les uns les autres et
partager partager
voilà de tous ceux qui veulent voir la
vidéo dans les rues ça brasse les uns
les autres
et en fait la première manière c'est pas
la langue mais c'est moitié alors en
gros tu veux mais toi mais attendez mais
dans le sens et non sa balle à manger
[Musique]
les deux personnes mais avec deux
moitiés
fait que la relation qu'on peut avoir
[Musique]
dans l'idéal il faut 4 moitié moitié
moitié moitié et lui avec sa moitié son
autre femme et que tous les tchats on
arrive à passer des moments agréables
voilà le prince william qui est sacré
chauve le plus sexy de la planète
oui étude réalisée par une société
britannique spécialisée dans la
chirurgie esthétique grand sondage 12
millions d'internautes ont répondu
résultat sans appel le prince william
arrive nettement en tête à ça c'est pas
du tout joué à un cheveu la star
d'armageddon et 8e dwayne johnson the
rock seulement 9e légèrement mauvais
perdant il a réagi sur twitter je
demande un recomptage
le grand gagnant lui ne s'est pas
exprimé le triomphe modeste d'emprunt ce
qui a mis du temps à assumer sa calvitie
l'assumé c'est peut-être ça le secret
plusieurs études sérieuses démontrent
que les chauves sont perçus comme plus
charismatique est dominant julien est
effectivement un séducteur
non je dirais que j'ai un passé un petit
peu vous le scellement qu'on puisse dire
j'ai enchaîné par mal de conquêtes gt20
donjon dans ma région
hgt maillot à pois meilleur grimpeur
incroyable dont la mère à face à part ça
si des baux est ton caleçon il est
pourri ça va ça on était sur une plage
avec coucher de soleil
c'est dans une paillote au bord de l'eau
d'accord et puis d'un coup il commence à
me comparer à une deux chevaux alors
qu'ils comparent ses ex à des ferrari
donc gelé et rénales tri voyez-vous vie
ah oui to9 aussi évaporée oui et théo
dépravés voilà des qualificatifs que
pour des femmes
quelquefois
[Applaudissements]
remplie yeux c'est mieux deuxième
définition paf eu de chute
alors on va regarder combien de lettres
à s'il est invité au la cruche
ouais ça pourrait la marche
oui oui on avait pensé à gourde mais
cruche ça marcherait j'espère
franchement que les mauvaises ne vont
pas arriver ce site parce que là c'est
pas vraiment un look pour les accueillir
et je te plains commenté
ah mais moi je me suis fait vous kiffez
refait sa vie
j'étais claquée quand même vécu sur un
carrelage froid personne peut faire ça
ne c'est pas possible
j'étais pour un carnage avait payé ce
sujet les froids et ça marcherait
d'écouté qui peut dire aujourd'hui j'ai
rencontré ma femme meurt c'est un grand
écart
jackie chan peut-être c'est tout je me
suis rapproché d'une fille on s'embrasse
et mais on est partant et pas s'ils
peuvent faire des choix pierre gibrat
bien attention pas entendu tu as dit
quoi c'est quand je me suis rapproché
d'une fier comment ça
je me suis rapproché n'est plus attends
je suis ta main j'ai tu te rapproches
d'une haute marche
c'est ça et je suis pas content du lien
parce que dans une mairie il faut avoir
un interlocuteur vous avez forcément un
maire adjoint permanence obligatoire
petite heure voilà donc non je parle de
l'avenir une petite bedaine quoi le
troisième étant commandés
c'est quand même là vient certes de
pagaille quand on essaye un petit peu
bête de sauver les meubles et de quand
même je les soigne un cerf donc là avec
thibault et kevin on apporte le gâteau
tous les froids
ça
mais
deux visages
mais là quand même sans trois ans je
peux pas l'enlever ça pourquoi vous
regardiez générique bien sûr bien sûr
j'avais vu ces images avant de me
téléphoner bien sûr bien sûr et bon moi
tu fais partie du patrimoine tu fais tu
fais partie du patrimoine français tout
le monde te connaît est ce que tu as
fait c'est un classique
je connais pas mal de millionnaires mais
craignent le millionnaire non c'est pas
ça me dirait certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être le sentiment et je viens de le
voir de m'avoir déjà vu j'étais à votre
place il ya quelques années à une époque
on m'appelait greg le millionnaire bravo
non parce que je suis toujours pas
millionnaire
comment vous avez réagi justement ce
passage éclair si jeune si vite adapté
ce qui s'est passé en fait on qu'on
réalise une fois que c'est passé
de toute façon à ne pas le cours dû
subir parce que le la vague on a pris la
déferlante et puis on n'a pas eu le
temps de réaliser ce qui s'était passé
donc c'est après on produit reculé après
on mesure les conséquences que cela a
sur notre vie privée
c'est une professionnelle est évidemment
bas au subi certaines de ses
conséquences forcément vous avez raté ma
vie